So, I want to take up in volume 11, February the 2nd, 1917.
The world has become unbalanced because it has lost the thought of the passion.
As I was in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself, and I found my beloved
Jesus' old dripping with blood with a horrible crown of thorns, looking at me with difficulty
through the thorns.
He told me.
My daughter, the world has become unbalanced because it has lost the thought of my passion.
Well, I don't know what word you'd use nowadays a century later.
I don't know what word you would even use.
Unbalanced mightn't be half strong enough.
So, he lists five things, so the first one is, they're in darkness.
It has not found the light of my passion, which would illuminate it.
And as it would make known to it my love and how much souls cost me, it might turn to loving
the one, that's Jesus himself, who has truly loved it.
And the light of my passion, guiding it, would put it on guard against all dangers.
So, the first effect of that is spiritual darkness, okay?
Now, the second one is spiritual weakness.
It has not found the strength of my passion, which would sustain it.
The third one is impatience.
And this is what we're finding, people are not having patience about anything.
It has not found the mirror of my patience, which would infuse it, infuse in it cam and
resignation.
And in the face of my patience feeling ashamed, it would make it its duty to dominate itself.
That means to have self-control.
And one of the things you see missing in people today is self-control.
And that's why you have all these attacks and murders and so on.
The fourth thing is, it has not found the comfort of the pains of God, which sustaining
its pains would infuse in it the love of suffering.
Number five, in sin, it has not found my sanctity, which placing itself in front of it would
infuse in it hatred of sin.
Man has made an abuse of everything.
We'd agree with that, wouldn't we?
Because in everything he has moved away from the one who could help him, now there's the
source of the troubles we have today.
They've literally moved away from God.
They've moved away from grace.
They've moved away from salvation.
So they're left then with just simply the brute human being.
This is why the world has lost its balance.
It behaved like a child who no longer wanted to recognize its mother or like a disciple
denying his master, though that's the Judas position then, no longer wanted to listen
to his teaching or learn his lessons, and that's the position with so many Christians
today that they just don't want to hear about Christianity.
What will happen to this child and to this disciple?
They will be the sorrow of themselves and the terror and sorrow of society.
It's very interesting.
The terror of society is the awful things that they will be left doing.
Man is getting worse and worse, and I cry over him with tears of blood, Jesus said, and
we know that in the last century, that statues of Jesus crying tears of blood and a blessed
mother crying tears of blood have been found in many places.
So February 24, 1917, in receiving communion, the soul must be consumed in Jesus and give
him the complete glory of his sacramental life in the name of all.
So notice must be consumed in Jesus.
Having received communion, Louisa said, "I was holding my sweet Jesus tightly to my heart,
and I said my life, how I wish I could do what you yourself did in receiving yourself
sacramentally, so that you may find your own contentment, your own prayers, and your own
reparations in me, and I always beloved Jesus told me, my daughter, in this small circle
of the host, I enclose everything.
That's why we don't need to be running around to shrines.
Everything is in the host.
And this is why I wanted to receive myself to do complete acts, a complete act is a divine
act, that would glorify the Father wordily, and as souls would receive their God.
You have to put their God, ah, God is not English.
And I gave to them the complete fruit of my sacramental life, otherwise it would have
been incomplete for the glory of the Father and for the good of souls.
This is why in each host you will find my prayers, my thanksgiving, you don't need
the essence of thanksgiving, ah, and everything else which was needed to glorify the Father
and which the soul was supposed to do for me.
So if the soul fails, I continue my crafting in each host as if I were receiving myself
before each soul, but we can receive him for each soul as well in the divine will.
Therefore the soul must transform herself in me, yes you're fusing, form one single
thing with me, all of me in all of you, make my life, my prayers, my moans of love, my
pains for own, as well as my heartbeats of fire with which I would want to ignite them.
But I find no one who abandons herself as prey to my flames, now there's the challenge.
It's one thing to take in receiving Holy Communion, it's one thing to take everything
that is Jesus and make it my own, but do I abandon myself as prey to his flames?
Do I abandon myself to this incredible love?
Because if I do, he will transform me into love.
In this host I am reborn, I live, I die and I consume myself, but I find no one who consumes
herself for me.
Now notice the complete giving that is being asked there.
And if the soul repeats what I do, I feel myself being repeated as if I were receiving
myself once again and I find complete glory, divine contentment, outpourings of love that
match me and I give to the soul the grace to be consumed from my own consummation.
So he's asking us to enter deeply into him, fuse ourselves completely in him and ask him
to complete everything he wants to do in this sacrament in us, which can only happen when
we are fused in his divine will.
So let's turn to volume 12.
And of course the only reason why it is volume 12 is that her notebook ran out.
There isn't anything special between the last message and the next one, it's just the size
of the notebooks they gave her.
So if you have that notebook on the table, when it's finished it's finished, you have
to go on to another one.
So we're not going to be jumping sky high into volume 12, but as we go into it we're
going deeper and deeper into this wonderful mystery of the divine will.
Now we're into 1917, two major revolutions happened in 1917, March and October you have
the terrible Bolshevik revolution that changed not only Russia and all its satellite states
would change the world as well.
Now the tight union between the soul and God is never broken.
Now the tight union means that the divine will and the human will have clicked in permanently.
It's not going to change.
So you become inseparable with the Lord.
My usual state continues, Louisa said, and my beloved Jesus makes himself seen almost
like a flash and flying past.
And if I lament, he tells me, my daughter, my daughter, my daughter, poor daughter,
if you knew what will happen, you would suffer very much.
What will happen is the Bolshevik revolution.
And I in order not to make you suffer so much, try to escape.
In other words, I don't let you see everything.
You wouldn't be able to take it.
So as I returned to lament saying to him my life, I did not expect this from you, you
who seemed to be incapable and unable to be without me.
And now hours and hours and sometimes it seems you want to let the entire day go by.
She sees him every single day and she complains.
I don't know if you have a comment about that.
It's incredible, isn't it?
Jesus, he says, don't do this to me.
I say, find that amazing.
But at least you are listening to someone who is truly in love.
Now you have changed, he said.
Jesus surprises me and says, Cam, yourself, I have not changed.
I am immutable.
Now he's told her this many times, isn't he?
Even more I tell you that when I communicate myself to the soul and I have kept her clasped
with me, that is in the divine will.
I have spoken to her, I've poured out my love.
This is never broken between me and the soul.
Here's your Romans 8-39, nothing can separate us from the love of Christ, nothing.
At the most I change the way, now one way and then another, but I always keep inventing
how to speak to her and pour myself out to her in love.
But don't you yourself see that if I've not told you everything in the morning, I'm almost
waiting for the evening to say a word to you.
Here you have two lovers desperately needing to communicate and when they read the applications
of my passion, since I am with you, I pour myself up to the brim of your soul and I speak
to you about the most intimate things which I had not manifested until now, very important.
The thing that Jesus had not manifested until Louisa was the interior passion that he suffered.
The whole church knew about his external passion but knew nothing about the interior passion.
So that's the great gift to the world, one of them anyway, not manifested until now and
how the soul must follow me in that operating of mine, in other words, how we must enter
into that interior passion.
Those applications will be the mirror of my interior life and whoever will reflect himself
in it will copy my own life within himself, oh how they will reveal my love and my thirst
for souls and in each fiber of my heart, in each of my breads, thoughts, etc., therefore
I speak to you more than ever but as soon as I finish I hide and you not seeing me tell
me that I've changed even more I tell you that when you do not want to, sorry, when you
do not want to repeat with your voice what I say to you in your interior you hinder my
outpouring of love.
So Louisa never got used to the hide and seek that Greg seems to have accepted very easily.
And so Jesus is reminding her of this incredible gift that is given to the church through her.
So Mark the 18th 1917, the effects of fusing oneself in Jesus, a very important message.
I was praying fusing all of myself in Jesus and I wanted each thought of Jesus in my power,
look at that in my power, so as to be able to find life in each thought of the people,
to be able to repair with the very thought of Jesus and so with all the rest.
This is the translator being as awkward as he can possibly get, may God forgive him.
She says I fuse myself in the thoughts of Jesus because through that I want to reach
the thoughts of all human beings and I want to bring his thoughts to them to cure their
thoughts.
It's actually a simple statement but it's said awkwardly, is that okay?
So in Jesus' thoughts we find the thoughts of all.
And Jesus said my daughter, my humanity on earth did nothing other than link each thought
of the creature with my own.
So each thought of theirs reverberated in my mind, each word in my voice, each heartbeat
in my heartbeat, each action in my hands, each step in my feet and so with all the rest.
Now that's Psalm 139.
You know my thoughts before I think them, my words before I say them and this knowledge
is too great for me, Psalm 139.
With this Jesus said, I gave to the Father divine reparations for every thought, every
word, every heartbeat, every action of ours, if you give that a bit of thought you'll
be impressed.
With this I gave the Father divine reparations now.
Everything I did upon the earth I continue in heaven and the souls think their thoughts
pour into my mind, no harm to remember that every now and then is it?
As they look, I feel their gazes in mind and as though a continuous electricity flows
between me and them.
As the members are in continuous communication with the head and I say to the Father, my
Father, I'm not the only one who prays you, repairs, satisfies, appeases you, but there
are other souls who do so within me what I do.
The church has always told us that everything we think say and do should be through him,
with him and in him and that's even before we got to the divine will level.
So he says, even more with their suffering they make up for my humanity.
I want to give you a couple of verses for that.
Colossians 1.24, Philippians 3.10.
So Colossians 1.24, Philippians 3.10, Galatians 6.17 and Ephesians 6.20.
Now just a tiny little reflection there.
If all our thoughts, words, actions, motivations, everything flow in Jesus' thoughts, words
and everything, don't you think that prayer is easy?
I don't have to come a long distance to find him.
My thoughts are already there.
Have you ever, do you say to him, "But you know what I'm thinking?"
You know what you're talking about.
But you know what I want to say.
So actually it makes prayer very, very simple.
It means connection is immediate.
He's already reading your thoughts because you, we have a couple of instances in the
gospel where you have in chapter 2 of Mark, for example, where Jesus is dealing with a
crippled man and he reads the thoughts of the scribes and Pharisees and he said, "This
is what's going on in your head.
They must have hated them."
That not even their thoughts were private because they didn't realize just who he was,
you know what I mean.
But it should make prayer very simple for us.
The other side of that coin is that to make a pretense in the presence of God's utter
folly because he sees the pretense and he sees what's going on in your head at the
same time.
So to try and get around him and pretend that we're not actually saying what we're saying,
you know, to do what we do with human beings is utter folly.
And so the only thing that really works with him is direct communication.
Whenever I am confronting a situation that I don't know how to do it, I just say to him
put the thoughts into my mind and I just give it a minute or two.
Put the words on my lips and give it a minute or two.
You'd be surprised that the response you would give to the situation.
So, and it's just this thing that all our thoughts and everything flow in his.
And he said, "By fusing yourself in me, the soul repeats what I did and what I continue
to do.
But what will be the contentment of these souls who have lived their lives in me, embracing
together with me all souls, all reparations when they are with me in heaven.
They will continue their life in me, and as souls will think or will offend me with
their thoughts, these will reverberate in their minds and they will continue the reparations
that they did on earth."
Now, I think that's absolutely beyond brilliant.
Here we are on earth trying to live in the divine will, understanding that when we live
fused with him and we must fuse as often as possible, that we find all souls in him
and we find their thoughts, their everything.
And he says, "Even when you get to heaven, their thoughts will still be reverberating
in your minds and the acts in the divine will that you did on earth, the reparations will
continue as long as human beings are on the planet."
I think that's fantastic.
It reminds me of St. Therese saying that "I will spend my heaven in doing good upon
earth."
In other words, I will continue to try and save souls as long as there are souls to
be saved.
The souls in the divine will be together with me, Jesus said, "The centuries of honor before
the divine throne."
And as souls on earth will offend me, they will do the opposite acts in heaven.
Is that interesting?
They will guard my throne and they will have a place of honor.
They will be the ones who will understand me the most and they will be the most glorious.
Their glory will be all fused in mine and mine in theirs.
Now, I want to give you Revelation 3, verses 20 and 21, where Jesus says that for certain
souls he will let them share his throne.
And this is what he's saying here, "He will guard my throne."
So let your life be all fused in mine.
Now notice he says your life, not just a few bits of it.
Not just a few minutes here and there.
Let your life be all fused in mine.
Do not do one act without making it pass into me.
So this whole paragraph, I have a VIP on it.
And every time you fuse yourself in me, I will pour into you new grace, new light, and
will make myself the vigilant century of your heart so as to keep any shadow of sin
away from you.
I will guard you as my own humanity.
Isn't that fantastic?
I will command the angels to form a circle around you.
Thank you, Lord.
That's Hebrews 114.
The angels are sent as guardians to look after us.
That you may be defended from everything and from everyone.
Now that defending from everything and everyone is interior, like somebody can slap you on
the hand.
You know what I mean?
They can get at your body but they can't get at your will and your love.
So notice he's saying there that the key to reaching the heights of the divine will
is to stay fused.
Very simple.
You see, nothing that's here is actually difficult.
It's just that I find how am I going to remember all the bits.
You know, that's why it's so important to keep reading.
So March the 28th, 1917, "The I Love You of Jesus."
Continue in my usual state, my beloved Jesus just barely made himself seen but so afflicted
us to a row as pity and I said, "What's wrong, Jesus?"
And he said, "My daughter, there will be and will happen unexpected things."
Now you're talking about this Bolshevik revolution and to be all of a sudden and it was all of
a sudden.
And revolutions will break out everywhere.
All how things will get worse and all afflicted here remained in silence.
And Louisa said, "Life of my life, tell me another word, not all about these revolutions."
And Jesus answered her, "As though breathing over me," he said, "I love you."
And in that I love you, it seems that everyone and all things received new life because you
see God loves everybody.
And so Louisa repeated, Jesus say one more word and he said more, a more beautiful word
than I love you, I could not tell you.
And this I love you of mine fills heaven and earth.
It circulates in the saints and they receive new glory.
It descends into the hearts of pilgrim souls and some receive the grace of conversion.
Now what?
They receive different things according to their dispositions, okay?
Some receive the grace of sanctification.
It penetrates into purgatory and it pours over the souls like a beneficial Jew.
Isn't that beautiful?
And they feel refreshment from it.
And the elements feel invested with new life in fertilizing and in growing.
So all perceive the I love you of your Jesus.
And you know when the soul draws and I love you of mine from herself, when fusing herself
in me, she takes on the divine attitude and dissolving herself in me, she does everything
I do.
So every time we fuse, then we cause this great I love you of God to come down upon
the whole of humanity.
They need it more than they need air, don't they?
So Louisa said, my love, many times it's difficult to always maintain this divine attitude.
And there's Louisa clicking into the rest of us.
It's not that difficult for her being in a bed and undisturbed by anybody.
But the Lord explains later on that he often got Louisa to ask him questions that apply
to us rather than herself.
And when I read that first I just said, wow, she clicked into our problems, okay?
So Jesus said, and this is very, very important.
And for those days when you get out of the bed, backways, the day is too full, nothing
seems to work, and you say to yourself, oh, I forgot to fuse even for the last couple
of hours.
You know what I mean?
So how are you going to handle it?
He said, my daughter, what the soul cannot always do with her immediate acts, she can
make up for with the attitude of her goodwill.
Now shouldn't you really color that one?
She can make up with the attitude of her goodwill.
And I will be so pleased with it as to make myself the vigilant century of each thought,
each word, and each heartbeat.
In other words, he'll give the same responses he would do if you had fused because he knows
that if you could sit down for five minutes, you might remember you ought to be fusing.
And he knows us.
And I will place them inside and outside of me as my courtage, looking at them with so
much love as the fruit of the goodwill of the person else, only the fruit of goodwill
because it can't be the fruit of fusing because you didn't fuse, okay?
But you're not losing completely as you can see.
When the soul then fusing herself in me does her immediate acts with me, then I feel so
drawn to her, would you put a ring around the little word then after you've done the fusing?
In other words, when you get back to clicking in, then I feel so drawn to her that I do
what she does together with her and I transmute the operating of the soul into the divine.
So for the times that you forget, he actually takes your goodwill into account and looks
after you, but then he wants you to fuse again, go back up onto the divine level.
I take everything into account, he said, I reward everything, even the smallest things.
Remember, he said, a cup of cold water, okay?
And even just one good act of the will does not remain defrauded by the soul.
I think that's fantastic, it's the sheer generosity of the Lord towards us, okay?
So April the 2nd, 1917, the pains of privation of Jesus are divine pains.
And this is why it's so impossible for Louisa, it's because it's not just a human pain,
it's on another level.
So Louisa said, I was lamenting to my beloved Jesus about his usual privations and was saying
to him, my love, what a continuous death, each privation of you is a death that I feel,
but such a cruel and ruthless death that while it makes me feel the effects of death, it doesn't
let me die.
And so I want to give you Sam 63 and Sam 42.
My soul cries out to you Sam 63, Sam 42, I have nothing but tears night and day.
Remember that one?
Okay, I've not understood how the goodness of your heart can endure seeing me suffer
so many continuous deaths and then make me still continue to live.
And blessed Jesus came and at long last he tells her something she doesn't really know
about the privations and this is very important.
My daughter Jesus said, press yourself to my heart and draw life as John 14, 6.
I am the way, the truth and the life.
You know however that the pain most satisfying, most pleasing and most powerful, the one that
equals me the most and can stand before me is the pain of my privation.
In other words, she's been complaining about a great privilege because he said it is a
divine pain.
You must know that souls are so bound with me as to form many links connected together
within my humanity.
And as souls become lost, they break these links and I feel the pain as if one member
were detaching itself from another, that's 1 Corinthians 12, 12 to 30, that's the body
of Christ and all its links.
Now, who can join these links for me?
Who can weld them in such a way as to make the split disappear?
Who can make them enter into me again and to give them life?
It is the pain of my privation because it is divine, it's not just human.
My pain because of the loss of souls is divine.
The pain of the soul who cannot see me cannot feel me is divine.
And since both of them are divine pains, they can kiss each other, join together, stand
before each other and have such power as to take the souls, unlinked and connect them
with my humanity.
So he's letting Louisa see the extraordinary power that the privations have if she just
offers them to the Lord.
So she's got to change the reaction to the privations into divine currency.
My daughter, he said, does the privation cost you much?
And if it does cost you, do not keep as useless a pain of such great cost.
That applies to us at our levels of suffering as well.
Whatever you have to go through, don't lose the extraordinary gain that you will get by
fusing and uniting it with the sufferings of Jesus.
As I give it to you as a gift, now Louisa has never thanked him for this gift, is he?
Do not keep it for yourself, but let it fly into the midst of the combatants.
In other words, let us save the soldiers on the battlefield.
I don't know if this is the first time he has said that.
I teach different books at the same time, so I don't know where I'm quoting, but he
has told her before that she should let her prayers and her intercessions go and save
the soldiers who are out on the battlefields.
Snatch souls from amid the bullets, he said, and enclose them in May.
And as the weld and the seal place your pain.
Now you see, many of these soldiers will have violated God's will in all kinds of ways
as part of their whole experience of war.
And here the Lord is asking Louisa to do the healing and the welding of something together
so that these souls can be saved.
So to go straight off the battlefield into God, isn't that fantastic?
It's the sheer detail with which the Lord uses our sufferings and our prayer and our
intercessions.
It's the sheer detail of helping somebody else.
So she's saying to him, I feel as if I'm suffering death and he's saying, but they
are suffering death.
But they, many of them either have accidentally or otherwise broken from me, you can weld
us together.
You have incredible power and therefore you can save these souls.
You can snatch souls from amid the bullets and you can enclose them in May.
And as the weld and the seal place your pain and then let your pain go around through the
whole world to make it catch souls and to bring them all back to me.
Now notice we are redeemed through pain and love.
That's the way Jesus redeemed us, okay?
So we are redeemed through pain and love.
And that's what he's asking Louisa, use your love and your pain with mine.
So as you feel the pains of my privation, you will keep placing the seal of the reconnection.
And I have John 15, seven there.
Jesus wants us to bear abundant fruit, okay?
And fruit that will last and I'm going to leave it there for tonight.